guys you may have a warrant for your
arrest let me in your house where's your
gold if you don't tell me where your
gold is I'm going to take you to jail
all right I have a warrant for your
arrest tell me where your Bitcoin is we
think you do okay go look for it well
how they're not gonna find my gold
either of course we can't they can of
course they can they can look so they
can't it's physical and it exists well
isn't isn't your Bitcoin stored on
something physical you have like a flash
drive or even if you wrote down your
seed phrase on a piece of paper it's not
on a piece of paper it's in my head oh
your whole your whole seed phase is in
your head yes because I understand what
it means to be a sovereign individual I
do not take that life so then what if
you forget it why why well how do you
know well I
have what well where where are those I
can't tell you we'll see well maybe the
government will find that good luck it's
at the awesome awesome